a louisville police sergeant involved in
the raid that led to briana taylor's
death is
counter-suing her boyfriend officer
jonathan mattingly accuses kenneth
walker of causing him
severe trauma mental anguish and
emotional distress
mattingly was shot in the leg during the
confrontation that killed brianna taylor
walker is suing kentucky's attorney
general the louisville metro police
department and the city
our national correspondent jerica duncan
has a response from his lawyers
the law's not on their side the facts
are not on their side
and the truths are not other side
frederick moore one of kenneth walker's
attorneys says sergeant jonathan
mattingly's countersuit against his
client
is just the latest attempt to deflect
responsibility
for the events that led to the shooting
death of brianna taylor
how can you sue kenneth when he was
acting lawfully
mattingly's attorney kent wicker stated
in the counter suit
that walker's conduct in shooting
mattingly is outrageous and tolerable
and defends all accepted standards of
decency and morality
in a statement he added that sergeant
mattingly should use the legal process
to seek a remedy for the injury that
walker has caused him
walker maintains the police did not
announce themselves when they executed a
no knock search warrant related to a
drug case on taylor's apartment
back in march he says he fired a single
shot believing police were intruders
that single shot allegedly hit sergeant
mattingly in the thigh
but a portion of the kentucky state
police ballistics report obtained by cbs
news says it's inconclusive who fired
the shot that hit mattingly
walker spoke to gayle king earlier this
month about the moment he fired his
licensed gun
so you fire off a shot in what direction
well i know i wasn't like aiming it
straight ahead it was like
down towards the ground you know trying
to just you know scare them off
also this month sergeant mattingly spoke
publicly to abc news and the louisville
courier journal
and dismissed walker's version of the
events he said walker was not pointing
his gun at the ground
i saw his gun our postures were the same
looking at each other
when he fired that shot walker's legal
team says mattingly is attempting to
further victimize
and harass him you kill the guy's
girlfriend in front of him
you shoot at him over 30 times you
change his life and then on top of that
when he tries to exercise his
constitutional right
and receive justice for what's happened
to him
you then vindictively file a frivolous
lawsuit against him
for cbs this morning jerica duncan new
york
i have to say guys when i first heard
about the lawsuit i was seeing i thought
i heard it wrong and then i read it and
thought i must be reading it wrong i
don't understand officer
mattingly's strategy here i well you can
file a lawsuit about almost anything
gail it doesn't mean
is that how it works a judge will we'll
have we'll make a final decision on this
one